would somebody just please punch me in
the face again I don't know what are we
talking oh wait wait a second well that
was like she cheated on you first what
what sir office how could you I was
really very unhappy at that time listen
I don't know what to say it was
practically an accident
it was a long time ago it was and now
you all have a wedding to go to I'm
gonna call the movers nowadays people
are taking pictures right they have
their phones now they're out something
catches their eye they want to take it
but then the photos just sitting there
what if they take that photo and
instantaneously put it out there on the
line and they share it with their
friends that's Instagram
it already exists it's one of the most
popular apps in the world Facebook
bought em for like a billion dollars
oh no mine is very different than that
how is there something very different
than that because I'm on you're taking
the photo instantaneously you're putting
the photo out there on the line is it
online yeah I'm putting my photos out on
the line I'm quitting an exchange yeah
that's Instagram come on what did you
get Marvin you gave her a gun it is
America Frank everyone else has a gun no
idea what doing this
you know I'm talking to your killer a
cold-blooded killer as opposed to a
peace-loving killer I know what you
think you know
why am i drawing this
so I was right there not a mundane
excuse me
what's a mundane someone from the human
world well I'm not a human that whatever
and we'd all be happy to see you come on
down to the starlight
just north of the 101 in Van Nuys
California Henley nebula where we put
the nail in front of millions of people
okay slow no mo that's Michelle [ __ ]
they don't get all the flow barbecue
sauce I'm not a coward
go to kaolin
I'm not a coward
guitar
the time you've got head coming do you
got the you've got incoming
so pants off not towards you a few
things about Old West fighting first
times in the church steeple it's the
first place I'm going to look place
hotel window every time I guess there's
only one novice in their crew sometimes
the window guy is on the roof